i think if you stop kind of being
creative and writing and
using that muscle you kind of lose that
muscle and i think that's what had
happened and so i i wasn't getting all
these ideas anymore of like what i was
going to make
and how long was the original script the
the feature script um the feature script
was i don't know 100 pages or something
you know and i think it's turned into a
uh
hour and 40 minute movie i think yeah
was it originally called borrego yep
it's always been called borrego
it's
i hate naming things like i'm actually
horrible and picking titles and names
for things so my names are never that
original but you know borrego is the
name of the desert that the movie takes
place in and then in spanish it also
means like lamb or sheep and that that's
kind of has a connection also to the
character and kind of some of the story
so it made sense and in the end it kind
of became this word that you know not
everyone even knows how to say it and
it's it's kind of confusing but it's
it's a little mysterious and i think it
kind of works it works for the film and
draws people in i guess um
and
i yeah who knows we'll see i guess i
like it and the anza borrego desert is
right where like san diego and
baja california sort of crossover or
exactly it's onsboro desert is kind of
where the u.s mexico border meets on one
side surrounded by kind of the mountains
next to san diego on the other side and
then the salton sea on the other side so
it's it's really this kind of no man's
land of sorts of california where it's
this huge desert area that has very
little population really almost no towns
it's just this massive desert uh most of
it is this state park
um
and but it's a beautiful landscape um
you know stunning deserts and and there
really isn't a lot filmed there um
my
my parents had been going there to kind
of escape the seattle winters and so i
would go and visit them and that's how i
kind of get introduced to this this
landscape and
it just seemed like a a really
compelling place for a movie to take
place
what's the premise for borrego
so the premise for borrego is it's about
a young botanist who
moves to this really small town in the
middle of the california desert uh
she's there to study this invasive plant
that's growing out in the wild in the
desert and she's kind of leaving some
things in her life behind and so she
decides to go and take this job for
several months to be alone out in the
desert
and while she's there she's deep out in
the middle of the desert by herself uh
the sun's going down she's getting ready
to go drive back to town for the night
and all of a sudden this little tiny
airplane like an ultralight plane uh
crashes right next to where she is in
the desert and she goes over to see if
this person's alive if she can help
and
he is he is alive but there's there's
these packages of drugs uh scattered
across the desert floor
and
he she realizes that he's survived but
he's basically gonna shoot her and kill
her take her truck and go and keep
driving these drugs to where he was
supposed to be flying this plane
but she convinces him
that you know he has no idea where he is
it's the middle of the desert it's the
middle of the night there no roads
she's only been there a few days but she
tells him that she knows this desert
like the back of her hand and that if
she doesn't he doesn't kill her she'll
help him get to where he's going
and so they eventually basically end up
using each other to survive and get out
of the desert um meanwhile the person
who was supposed to receive these drugs
is like where are these drugs and goes
in to go find him
and there's a few other characters the
sheriff of the town his daughter um and
even though the film is kind of set in
this drug border world kind of story and
that's everything i just explained but
that's really not what the movie's about
the movie is really this movie of
survival and choices that people make
and from the beginning i really didn't
want to make a drug movie that's really
not what this is it's it's really this
kind of more personal movie of the
choices you make and and how those
impacts um basically
the rest of your life or or the other
people kind of uh around you and
the movie's kind of this just compelling
thriller basically in the desert lots of
action lots of emotion
and
hopefully a fun entertaining movie
and you wrote it for a female
protagonist
yeah um i think so the
the the original idea for the movie came
about because my dad is this amateur
botanist and he
was out in the desert in this real area
brego springs and he had found with some
of the people he had found this invasive
plant that was growing
and
this is a very tiny little town it's not
even its official city it's like
unincorporated san diego county
and so they were gonna basically try to
get a grant and bring a botanist in to
come and study this and help them figure
out how to eradicate it and he told me
that and i was like this is an amazing
setup for why someone would come to a
town and so from there i started
building out this idea of you know what
would someone be running away from and
why would someone come to this town
and um
and then after that kind of found an
article about a a drug plane
uh that had crashed somewhat nearby than
that desert and that they were using
these ultra lights which are basically
like gliders with a little tiny engine
like very janky little planes because
they fly so low and slow they don't
really get picked up by the radar you
know like a real plane would but they
also crashes because they're really
homemade sometimes and carrying lots of
drugs and so i kind of put those two
together i knew that to make a kind of
commercial appealing film that i needed
to have some sort of aspect like that
into it but i didn't i didn't want to
make a border movie or a drug movie i
wanted to to make a really personal
movie of survival and choices and so
that's kind of just what sets up this
whole action and becomes then a more
intimate film about this botanist um
and yeah i think i don't know i from the
beginning she was always a
a female character i don't that wasn't
like i was like oh i gotta make a female
character it was more just i guess what
made sense and
i i think quickly became really
compelling i mean
my mom was super strong like woman and
so i think i also just grew up like
around that and so i don't know i think
it was just it felt so i guess natural
to me which doesn't make sense because
i'm a man but it just was it felt almost
more natural to write that than to write
as a guy sure and the stakes are higher
in some sense because she's got to
survive and there's there's a fear
element of things yeah no for sure and
no i mean it becomes a really kind of
interesting dynamic you know in the
desert and
it's
um
you know a lot of people would expect it
to become like a love story or something
like that and it doesn't have any of
that it's it's it's really kind of this
just this story of of what are you
willing to to do how much are you going
to fight for what you want and
and what are those choices you're going
to make to to kind of
go one way or the other
how many feature scripts had you written
prior to borrego and how did you know
this was the right one to spend time
with
so i think this was the third
feature script i had written the first
was the one i made when i was 17 and
made this feature film instead of going
to college
and then i wrote another one a few years
after that with someone else
and it was a cool story and but nothing
really came from it um and then i went
and stopped basically my own film career
and ran this film festival for young
directors for
seven eight years and then i started
directing commercials and so i kind of
uh
got out of this path of of writing and
you know you kind of lose i think when i
was doing the festival especially i was
doing very like producer type things i
was raising money i was organizing
and
i think if you stop kind of being
creative and writing and and using that
muscle you kind of lose that muscle and
i think that's what had happened and so
i i wasn't getting all these ideas
anymore of like what i was going to make
and so i think what took it was my dad
had told me this this real story of of
um this invasive plant that had been
growing out in the desert uh where he
was working as a volunteer botanist and
that triggered something because it was
like this this connection to him and i'd
spend my childhood actually spending a
lot of time in the desert with my
parents we would always go to the desert
and so the desert was this very special
place to me and so i could almost see
instantly this the whole story kind of
put together and visualize it i knew it
was going to be a compelling place
and so yeah i mean obviously it took a
lot of time it wasn't like the first
draft was okay it's done it was several
years of writing and revisioning and
getting feedback from people to make it
a really strong film but i almost think
if there was something about taking all
this time off and having some more life
experience doing some other stuff that
then gave me even more kind of power
behind it to then be able to go and
write something really strong when i
when i had that idea that i was really
excited about
how long did it take you to write the
first draft oh it probably took maybe
six to seven months maybe for our first
draft i mean i wasn't
it was i wasn't writing it every day or
anything like that you know i mean it it
it uh
it probably took
longer than it would if i was gonna just
sit down and do it now or something
right but then
from there i probably spent another year
or two
refining it and doing a few more
versions of it um maybe not quite that
long but at some point in there i had
started to get to get the idea that i
needed to do this proof of concept and
so i think i was i was working on the
proof of concept why i always continue
to refine the feature too
and i mean you're still rewriting and
changing things even while you're
filming and beyond you know so it you're
never finished with it but
it definitely
i think took many rounds of getting
feedback and revisions to kind of get it
to a place where it was ready to really
share and be something you could send
out to everyone